Yeah.
Rolling.
[inaudible]
that's what they decided to do to them to make it look like they found his body.
He was 22 and I'm sure he was probably involved with a bunch of waves as the
evening.
Some of the unscrupulous intentions,
you know,
just David Carradine,
he was in conflict with,
he likes to party,
notorious accidental mechanical at 68 was found hogtied wearing too wet
dialing gloves and slippers,
rubberized underwear and a headmaster pork right here.
Investigations.
Gary all just his death was not caused.
Yeah,
that looks fine.
What's your definition of the 51 year old pastor wasn't voted as home at the
time.
We'd gone apparently in the mess.
Yeah.
Wow Man.
Yeah,
that's fine.
All right,
we ready?
Oh,
what police?
That's it.
They chose not to mention what police discovered inside the ministers rubber
briefs.
And if you click on that link they found a giant black.
So
Ah,
ah,
corked and Jamie here recording audio of all of this.
Yes.
We're uh,
we're in the kitchen with Tonka trucks.
Haul got allergies or something.
Does the podcast studio has been transformed because a big part of the new Scifi
show deals with the podcasts are,
he's in it.
And so it's young Duncan Trussell and uh,
we're filming a lot of the guests and some of the discussions here,
uh,
at the studio.
So if you could see this is usually not cluttered and crazy and uh,
they,
they changed the decorations a little.
They gave us this,
this fucking stupid thing.
I don't know what that is,
but it makes it more saifai whatever.
Um,
so today was a doctor Jeffrey Meldrum.
He's a lead shit scientists who heavily believes in bigfoot,
I don't know,
but fun stuff.
And we'd been going nonstop.
The show starts airing July 16th,
and where,
uh,
the schedule's just been ridiculous,
but we're meeting a lot of really cool people and so far as Lana,
pretty cool shit.
And that's all the crew back there.
Think of times that a lot of shit to show you fuckers for.
Shit,
I'm so tired.
I haven't slept right in days.
I've been fine.
All of the fucking world.
I flew from Canada to New York,
New York,
North Carolina,
North Carolina here,
and from here we got to go to Texas.
Dunkin's going to go to or no.
Dot.
He's going to go to Colorado and I got to go to Texas and then I got to go to
Alaska.
But it's gonna be bad ass.
Hopefully it'll suck either way.
I'll tell you,
I'll create a pseudonym.
I'll go online.
I'll tell you my show stock.
That'd be really obvious though.
They'll be like,
whoa,
job until where are you said telepathy already exist in the form of language,
right?
With language.
Your mouth is making certain sounds and then you run those downs through a
cultural context.
A dictionary of sure.
What we've accepted that those sounds represent.
And through that I can read your mind.
Yeah.
And that's what you're doing.
When you were describing to me your encounter,
meeting your friend,
and while you're jogging and various coincidences that have happened through
your life,
I'm essentially reading a version of your thoughts on the,
on these subjects and dad is telepathy.
And that is what separates human beings from other animals.
That what we're dealing with as far as like what we call psychic energy might
just be a,
we are,
we are slowly emerging and we were slowly developing these,
these potential abilities and a guy like band a check may be able to come along
and dismiss all of these because they're not as tangible as a noise that comes
from your mouth.
Maybe it takes a million years to develop these abilities and maybe right now we
just,
the whispers of these abilities are possible maybe where it's like a radio
station that you can only tune in during a thunderstorm,
but it's just like it was tiny weird phenomenon that only happens like upon
occasion.
That is possible.
It is certainly possible.
And another thing about psychic energy that makes it fantastic and very
interesting to discuss is the fact that so many people have claimed to
experience it and so many people I think almost recognized at a genetic level
that that's coming and that is an emerging aspect of human consciousness and the
ability to do it nonverbally
yeah,
I mean yeah,
it's one I can say one thing is indisputable right now.
There is no accepted proof that this exists.
There's no accepted proof.
We don't know.
We don't know that it exists right now that is indisputable and that does not
mean that it doesn't exist.
And that's what's really cool about the scientific method and this approach to
truth is it,
it isn't committed one way or the other.
It's not.
And I don't even think vantage check was completely closed off to the idea that
it wasn't real.
Yeah,
it was.
I thought for a moment he said,
I don't know,
may,
I thought there was like something in,
they're always like,
it hasn't been proven,
but maybe I don't remember.
Maybe I just,
well thanks for checking.
You might've put that in asleep.
So yeah,
you said me
said maybe it's weird.
I want,
one thing that I love about this show,
what it's done to me is if you think I'm a hippie now before the show I was much
more of a heavy,
and then you come into contact with people who are really in believing this
thing or that thing and won't listen to logic.
And then that becomes really appalling when you realize that from an
individual's POV it's kind of sad or cute or whatever.
But from a group of people believing in things that aren't provable,
that shit gets really bad.
And also I,
one thing that vantage has pointed out,
which I really liked just how dangerous it is,
a,
when people decide to use methods that are easily recreated to actually get
money from people and pray on the their vulnerabilities,
like they miss a loved one,
they show them a few parlor tricks,
makes maybe think that they have these abilities and then suddenly they're
taking money from them to let them talk to their grandparents who've done or
their parents have died that's evil.
And then you take that one step further and you get the priest class who
convinces groups of people that they can talk to God.
And then they start churches and religions.
And then the next thing you know you've got an even deeper problems.
So I think that stuff that vantage check does and that skeptics do,
it's really important and good.
And it's important to be skeptical,
but you can't be skeptical to the point where you step on your own experience,
where your skepticism override something that you've actually experienced.
Yeah.
But isn't it possible that skepticism not overrides what you've actually
experienced but defines it explains it?
Well,
if,
if it,
if it can be explained,
if it can be explained.
Yeah.
So far everything you've said,
I believe can be explained.
Yeah.
I,
and also just because something can be explained,
it doesn't mean that it's no longer special,
are wonderful.
It just means that now you know what it is.
Yes.
I agree with that.
I think that's really important and I become much more of a skeptic because of
the show as well.
Um,
and talking to people that believe in things.
You also recognize these patterns that exist over and over again and people that
believe in things and it's that they don't ever contemplate the contrary.
They don't,
they don't ever consider whether or not what they believe in is nonsense.
They just go forward with sort of this,
this blind conviction that what they're,
whether it's about aliens or psychics or big foot or whatever it's about,
they go forth with this conviction that they have the truth and they want to
expose the truth.
I think that can function
because of his head sled over until I can come.
Cause when you touch my butt,
who wants to live forever?
Yeah,
let's kill life after life still running.
We're rolling
white terror,
silver.
Come by.
Fear.